growing up as an Asian American in New
Jersey she often looked for a sense of
belonging she found it when she became a
part of the hospitality industry and now
she welcomes the world to her many
Philadelphia area restaurants she's
gotten Acclaim scoring top ratings and
multiple James Beard award nominations
along with other industry honors
ladies how are your salads when it comes
to the classic meet and greet Ellen yen
is a pro you said you're from Philly for
a quarter of a century her restaurant
Fork has been a Mainstay in
Philadelphia's old city and Yin though
not a chef is eager house lunch to feed
her diners desires any feedback any
wishes let us know what has kept me
fueled is connection connection with the
community connection with my team
members having a place that people want
to call home this is my home so when you
walk in the door Michelle you're you're
in my house
the food here is locally sourced and not
for Waste Watchers I love carbs so it's
a lot of carbs here I see you like cars
I love carbs and I love bread she
provided us with a taste from all of her
restaurants starting with local grains
from High Street one of my all-time
favorite ones Sesame sourdough you you
kind of give me quite a slice here it's
served with Tzatziki with that is
Harissa there's a white bean salad
Brassica salad and a little cheese with
zatar Suzuki is on point I love that and
from a Kitchen and Bar there was a beet
salad octopus with leonase and pork
belly lardon and a soft-boiled egg with
trout Roe we also have spockatelli so
like I said I love pasta rice potatoes
all those type of things that served
with a porcini and pork Ragu with Crispy
leeks also on the table Forks Mushroom
on entree a mix of trumpet mushrooms
lion's mane and fresh herbs what is that
sauce it's pureed parsnip oh
delightful there's also Pennsylvania
brook trout
and then of course I'm a cookie holic
I'm addicted to cookies so these are
pink peppercorn meringues Rye chocolate
chip cookies and oatmeal fluffernutter
this is my favorite so it has pink
peppercorn chocolate and sesame all
right
mmm it's like a shortbread oh it's
delicious with the chocolate on
her passion for entertaining started at
home I got this love for Hospitality
from my family from my mother who was
always entertaining large groups of
people at home she would debone this
chicken make sticky rice and then stick
it back in the chicken truss it up and
then bake it this is something that
would take hours and also that our
family and extended family could come
together and you know celebrate being
together Yen and her siblings were
raised in New Jersey by immigrant
parents what was growing up as a Jersey
girl a Jersey girl an Asian American
Jersey girl when I grew up in New Jersey
I grew up in a small little town in
Monmouth County there were very few
Asians in our community I just always
struggled with feeling like I belonged
in school well thank you so much for
coming in and enjoy your lunch and that
feeling stayed with her later in life I
never really looked at myself as an
Asian woman
in the mirror of course when I look in
the mirror I see myself as Chinese
but I never thought about all the things
that it takes to create your identity
and your story and and how all the
things that
you experience in your life become part
of you she decided to pursue Hospitality
after working at a local restaurant in
high school but her parents had
different ideas while my father's dream
was for me to become an engineer and he
was so disappointed when I
failed physics in high school you failed
business I didn't fail but I gotta see I
thought it was true yeah I I was not
good I wasn't either I just couldn't
understand it but my father couldn't
understand why I did not understand
physics and he felt it was a personal
affront to him that I couldn't grasp the
concept of of gravity
still her father an engineer at Bell
Labs pushed her to the University of
Pennsylvania she thought an MBA in
Health Care Management might be a bridge
between her heart and a corporate career
I could just never find it every job
that I had I just kept going back to the
restaurant industry that I loved so much
you're going to teach me how to make
dumplings yes I am your mama's dumpling
my mom's dumpling so we're gonna we're
gonna put a spoonful in the middle okay
is that too much or is that perfect that
looks pretty good okay yeah turn to
dumpling making during the pandemic with
the wonton project finding Connection in
isolation during an era of Asian
American hate we have donated money to
advancing Justice which is a National
Organization in Philadelphia Asian
Americans United and it is designed to
provide These funds on an ongoing basis
this is really you sort of rediscovering
for Heritage and crisis absolutely
equally important as her Heritage is her
community mayor Nutter asked if I would
serve on the board because they were
looking for business people who are
interested in the development of the
Waterfront it's all come full circle for
Yen who's a five-time James Beard best
restaurant tour nominee restaurant tours
are way more than just chefs or maitre
days or managers they really are
important to the community and even as a
nominee I feel it's my role to continue
representing the industry well in that
sense and pushing it forward
Fork really has established that area of
Market Street and folks come for the
Breads and the pastries and so much more
her scone here is delicious stones are
usually dry this is just like when not
doing properly and delicious
the rhubarb pie the rhubarb hibiscus
Daiquiris yeah you stole a cookie it's
delicious it's also good